if you leave your time to randomness
you are stealing from your greatness
install
environments of tight bubbles of total
focus
so many of you complain about how much
time you have you don't have time man
because you don't beat the sun up get
started early
wanna be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you you've got
michael jordan level talent at something
so today let's live your best believe
life and learn the seven ways to become
more productive
okay let's kick it off with way number
one start small with thomas frank
what's a tip that you might have for
somebody who's trying to be more
productive where do you even start with
that really
i think the biggest thing is to start
small so one of the
one of my favorite lessons i learned
early on in college came from this book
called the motivation hacker
by this guy he's a quantified self dude
out in
california and he tried to do all these
crazy habits all at once and kind of
documented his journey and talked about
what he learned
and he had this concept in the book
talked about called success spirals
where you have to start very small when
you're wanting to build a habit
and then you kind of spiral up and you
add more difficulty you add more habits
over time
because you're sort of leveling up and
then if you fall off you need to start
small again
you can't start immediately we were so
what i see in most people who start
following me and asking me
you know how do i become more productive
they want to do all these things all at
once
start getting up it's five in the
morning they want to start journaling
you want to start meditating
start reading you know a book a week all
this kind of stuff and you can't do it
immediately
so the biggest thing for me is to find
something that speaks to you
and start with that and make sure you
can get it really solid so start with
one
yep and then start small what do you
mean by start small
uh it could be so say you want to start
doing pull pull-ups every day start by
doing one pull-up a day
or start by just making yourself go to
the gym and just getting there that's
you know that's the accomplishment for
you yeah and then start moving forward
because a lot of people
they see like a recommended program from
a pro online
and they'll say okay i'm going to do
that every single day because that's
what i need to do
but when you haven't spiraled up like
nick says
you can't stick with that kind of a
program unless you're some sort of you
know ridiculous discipline robot
so you want to start smaller and then
eventually you can stick to that
kind of a big program do you have an
example of a habit that you've done
that you've spiraled up on yeah uh so i
mean i guess my whole morning routine is
a good example of you know been able to
add things to it over time
but with pull-ups you know i bought a
door frame pull-up bar to one reduce the
friction and make sure i could do it
more often
uh but two then start doing more and
more every single day and start with you
know like five a day
and now i probably do 20 or 30 a day out
of one set but oh i was gonna say like
geez man that's crazy no i think i'm up
to 15 in one set with chins
and then 12 in one set with pull-ups and
how long did it take you to get that
i don't know i didn't really track it
so for that kind of a habit i just
thought all right the the bar is in the
door
so it's kind of like an if then
statement a program if i go into the
office i do
five or six pull-ups or if i want to
take a break from my work i just go over
and do some pull-ups
way number two automate and delegate
with tim ferriss
i'll tell you how i look at this in the
simplest form and one of the frameworks
should sound familiar if you've read the
four hour work week
80 20 analysis i will look at and i do
this in fact instead of
for instance new year's resolutions i do
a review of my entire calendar
previous year week by week for in this
case we
just came into 2018 i'll look at 2017
and i will make a list in fact two lists
of the the 20 of people and activities
who produced 80
of my peak positive emotional states
that's one list
the other side 20 of people or
activities that produced 80
of my peak negative emotional states
and it could be as simple as frustration
and what this will help you to put
together it doesn't have to be at the
end of the year
is a to-do list all right to focus list
and then a not to-do list
all right and i tend to focus on these
days at least
taking disagreeable tasks or distracting
tasks
and first trying to automate them with
software
auto pay whatever it might be right a
repeating schedule with a taskrabbit for
instance for physical pickup or anything
like that
perhaps you do that through a ups store
that scans and then emails your
documents or earth class mail
use technology whenever possible instead
of
brute force with humans right even if
they're humans involved in conjunction
with technology
so i'll try to automate as much as
possible first
then if we're looking at delegating
which frequently includes technology
again i'll try to remove the negative as
much as possible especially with
repeating
tasks that is the lowest hanging fruit
then
i will look at my primary projects for a
given period
of time and if you have let's just say
four or five projects you could pursue
or that are in play in your life
i will i will narrow it down by asking
which of these projects if moved ahead
to the next milestone or if completed
will make
all of the rest either irrelevant or
make all the rest easier and i've done
this in fact recently in the last week
then we have a primary focus this is the
lead domino that will make everything
else easier
i will throw as much at that as possible
so let's just say hypothetically
we are trying to design a website
in some cases you want to throw money at
a problem doesn't have to initially be a
lot of money
but throw money at a problem instead of
time time is non-renewable
so i will say go to 99designs and get
50 different submissions to brainstorm
ideas for a potential website
hire perhaps two firms and have them all
at the same time
working on designs so that i can save
time and move this project
ahead as quickly as possible with as few
stops
as possible if for instance i need a
legal opinion all right well
i'm going to look for a consensus i'm
going to look for gaps to be filled by
different
people i will very frequently have two
or three people work on that at the same
time and then gather their responses
again just to quickly review the not to
do list based on
the 20 of activities people that tend to
produce 80
of my negative emotional states and then
the to-do list
based on looking at your list of
projects and identifying
the project will that will make the
others either irrelevant
unnecessary to do or easier that is the
lead domino and then i throw as much as
possible at that
which does not need to cost a lot of
money and certainly for me has not cost
a lot of money even when i was
i'm not going to say in the poor house
but really really scraping by and very
little you can still find ways to do it
because there is talent both overseas
domestically and there are many
different types of software
that can help you to smooth out and
simplify process to make them much more
elegant
way number three build more discipline
with brendan burchard
if you're not doing block time here's
what your day might look like
you have all these different slots of
time right
and you're just going to plug in as you
go through the day
you're going to plug in oh i'll work
some there and i'll work some there
and then i'll try to cram stuff up right
at the end of the day i'll try to cram
that sucker in
any crammers crammers crammers cameras
okay just checking
no judgment no judgment you're just not
going as fast as you could
that's all crammers they're i love
crammers
yeah just like because they're easy to
get to move faster because you do have
that diligence
of when there's a deadline and it's on
you can go which
really serves you but we got to take you
from a crammer to a preparer to a high
performer
and the way that we do that is to look
at this and go
listen if you keep leaving all these
time slots to randomness
what happens
is they start to get filled
with the big d
distraction
[Applause]
some reason it seems like this hit home
for some people
i don't know why how many recognize what
i'm talking about here
so now you add up
take this out you might not be thinking
too seriously about it but let's say
that's like a day
one two three four five six seven eight
work hours
you didn't know i drew that on purpose
if you leave your time
to randomness you are stealing from your
greatness
if you leave your time to randomness you
are stealing from your greatness
bit by bit hour by a hour day by day
week by week month by month
quarter by quarter year by year and
decade by decade and it's the little
things
like this where you're like oh my gosh i
didn't get
anything done because you've got all
these random approaches
to your day my friend evan carmichael's
book listen
humans are built to serve some people
are built to serve the world
others want to serve the 25 people
closest to them
but in either case humans are built to
serve so if you're not happy right now
it's because you're not serving enough
you got to pick up this book because
it's so inspiring to remind you that
we're all here to contribute
to make a difference to make an impact
and this is your field guide for that
way number four create an environment of
total focus
with robin sharma your environment is so
important
and if you look at b performers or c
producers
they really don't pay a lot of attention
to their environment and so they get
very distracted there's lots of noises
their phones are going off maybe there's
news in the background
maybe there's messy environments all
around them
maybe there's toxic people what i'm
suggesting to you
as the second piece of technology to
really 100
times your productivity is this install
environments of tight bubbles of total
focus
the way i run my work life on certain
days
i am very hard to reach and i challenge
you with great love and respect
be very hard to reach during key times
of your week i mean i see a lot of
people
and it's not judging them it's just
observing them every time their phone
rings they
check it or they have you know these
loud notifications
so they're constantly being distracted
and we know what the research says
the research says we spend 2.1 hours a
day
in distraction we spent and it takes
21 minutes to refocus your focus after
you've been distracted
so if you are being distracted by
notifications checking your phone
checking your twitter feed checking your
facebook feed looking on instagram
checking all the different platforms
that is going to destroy your focus
so the second piece of technology is
create these tight
bubbles of total focus and the way i do
it is
i have certain days that i label as
creative days
and on those creative days i actually go
device
free and on those days i'm very hard to
find
and on those days i'm in total solitude
and on those days
i go to certain places i call them my
menlo
labs just like edison had his menlo lab
and these places are very minimalist
and there's no one there and that's
where i do
my best work so install these tight
bubbles of total focus
and create these menlo labs where you're
so
you're completely distraction free and
then you will find your brain will
drop from the beta state into the alpha
state
where you will do your best work and get
your best ideas
way number five beat the sun up with
grant cardone
grant rant of the day the one you need
to live with wake up to every day
is that right there okay
beat the sun up folks you got to beat
the sun up if you can't beat up the
roll-up of the sunnah
you're going to get beat up in life okay
i've been doing this for a long time now
say beat that thing up that monster out
there that warms this planet
that nourishes and gives us light
but you can't live a 10x life if you're
not beating the sun up
so many of you complain about how much
time you have you don't have time man
because you don't beat the sun up get
started early
and when you get started early that
means you need to shut it down early
okay shut it down early so you get sleep
i was i was asleep last night at nine
o'clock
so i could beat the sun up tomorrow this
morning and see
the world wake up with me way number six
set appropriate goals with jordan
peterson you don't
tell your kid here is an impossible
thing
why don't you go out and fail you say
here's something worth going after
here's a step you could take that would
push you beyond where you are
but that you also have a reasonably high
probability of succeeding at
right they call that within a time frame
within some time frame that's the other
thing you have to parameterize it with
regards to time frame that's right
and that puts you in the zone of
proximal development and that's a that's
a concept that was generated by a guy
named vygotsky he was a russian
developmental psychologist and a smart
one it's where the idea of the zone
comes from to be in the zone
and when you're in the zone you're
expanding your skills
at in a manner that's intrinsically
rewarding
because you're succeeding and so you
want to set if you're good to yourself
you think okay i need to set a goal
but i need to set a goal that someone as
stupid and useless as me
could probably attain if they put some
effort into it
then you got then you've got it
perfectly because it's not so high that
it's grandiose or impossible that you
fail necessarily and then justify your
bitterness it's like well i could do
well because that happens to people
happens all the time
yeah it's like this all the time you
know it's like it's yes exactly well i
set a goal and i didn't attain it so i'm
not going to set any more goals right
it's like no you set a goal that was
inappropriate for the time
frame that's right you didn't calibrate
it properly and and you're playing a
trick on yourself because you wanted to
fail so that you could justify not
having to try
and being a victim yeah which isn't
helpful you're still going to be
a victim it's like there's no way out of
that man so
you know because life is this life is a
challenge that in some sense can't be
surmounted so there's no way out of your
problem
but there are certainly proper ways of
dealing with it and way number seven the
last one before a very special bonus
clip is improve your efficiency with
gabrielle bernstein
many of us have issues with productivity
maybe we are overly productive but we're
feeling burned out all the time
or we're not productive at all because
we don't know where to start i found
personally being in business for myself
for the last
20 years that i have been a little
overly productive i almost did too much
and i was
constantly multitasking and making
things happen and just moving
so fast that ultimately i really burnt
out
and i started feeling brain fog i was
feeling disoriented i couldn't focus i
was feeling like
even though i for so many years was
priding myself on the fact that i could
get so much done at one time
i actually don't think i was being
nearly as productive as i could have
been
so i hit a bottom recently with this
productivity overload
and i realized that i had to change my
patterns i had to change my ways
i was then blessed um i said a prayer i
said i need some help with my brain fog
and i need some help with my
productivity issue
and i that day got an email from the dr
oz show asking me to come on and do a
segment with
this lovely author and doctor dr mike
dao
and me and mike had been in touch many
years for many years just because he
hadn't been an author we were published
by the same publishers
and mike had written a book about brain
fog so that day
i'm like thank you universe you're
giving me exactly what i need
i go on dr oz with mike and i'm
backstage with him and i'm like listen
i'm feeling
so chaotic and i'm multitasking so much
and my
i feel like i've got brain fog and i'm
forgetting things and he looked at me
says how much are you doing at one time
and i said oh mike i'm doing a million
things at once i have a thousand tabs up
on my screen
and he's like these are big brain
no-no's and they're also productivity
no-no's is what he said
because he said that the more i try to
do and the more i try to multitask
the less i'm actually getting done so he
gave me a tip that i want to share with
you that has changed
everything for me and his suggestion was
to just do five
things a day to make a list of the five
most important things that i need to do
that day
and not do number two until i've
completed number one
and then once i complete number one move
on to number two then on to number three
and if i don't get through all five in
one day i'll just pick up the fifth
the next day or wherever i left off i'll
pick up the next day
and to really stick to that list and not
move back and forth and not try to make
a million other things
added on to that list and just be really
committed to that five
task list i did it i started to just be
very clear about the five things i was
doing in a day i told my team
i made a a list in my base camp which is
where we keep all of our notes
and i made it really clear to myself
these are the only five things i'm doing
throughout the day as a result of making
it
super clear and conscious to myself that
i was only going to do five things
i have been more productive i have
created more i have been more
intuitive i have been more inspired and
i've been more creative
now i've got a really special bonus clip
on how you can stop
procrastinating that i think you're
gonna enjoy but before that it's time
for the question of the day
i wanna know which of these seven ways
to be more productive are you
going to apply immediately into your
life let me know put it down in the
comments below and if you made it this
far in a video you're still here
watching i want to celebrate you because
believe nation we don't just watch
videos we do
something about it so that's you and you
commit you promise you're going to take
action
immediately after watching this video
give me a hashtag
believe down in the comments and tell me
where you're from because i want to
celebrate
you
recognizing that you're procrastinating
right that's that's the hardest part
because you'll find really smart okay
great so
then are you afraid of it or you you
just don't want to do it
well let's say you're crosstalking
dishes i don't think you're afraid of it
so so you just don't want to do it but
at some point you're going to want to do
it because otherwise this
dishes will stack insanely high and then
you won't like going into your
to figure out kitchen do i get to it
before
waiting for that moment where it's like
now i have to do it like there's no
other option
yeah i mean listen if washing dishes is
the biggest thing you're procrastinating
over then
like well but but like
so what's that what's a bigger example
where you're
you either don't want to do it or you're
afraid of it
like what are you actually
procrastinating on
okay so you don't want to do it or
you're afraid of it
[Music]
that's just a cover right like that's
just an excuse you don't know how to do
anything what do you do you go
you go find it you could have researched
already and know how to start a website
instead of being here tonight like you
could already have the answer how long
have you been thinking about having a
website
[Music]
you're a smart person like you could
have figured it out the next day
maybe not all the answers but you could
have built momentum on it so why are you
not
figuring out how to do it because
everything is solvable right it's just a
skill set
why am i not doing it because you either
don't want to do it or because you're
afraid
so it's like it's one of the two like
you either really don't want to have a
website and you feel forced that you
have to have this website and it's
stupid and you'd rather not
or you're afraid of launching a website
it's not going to be good and it's not
going to be perfect and people are going
to look at it
and not buy your services and laugh for
you it's going to just be this giant big
waste of money
[Music]
well that's okay i mean it's never a
skill set issue because you can always
learn
if you took the past two months or three
months of thinking about it
you could have made your own website let
alone like
hire somebody or partner with somebody
or ask friends hey do you know anybody
who can help with my website
so it's one catching procrastination
because a lot of times we won't catch it
a lot of times we find a really smart
reason i can't do it because i'm busy
because
i'm doing this and i got all these other
things and you're a smart person so you
find really
smart reasons why you can't do something
right not just you me
everybody right but when you catch it
what's the reason you either don't want
to do it
and so move away it's like people who a
lot i get a lot of dms from students who
are in
university who don't want to be there
anymore and they procrastinate on
studying and like i i
i never even wanted to join in the first
place or you get locked into a business
that you started that you liked at the
beginning but now you've bought yourself
a job and don't like it anymore it's a
lot of entrepreneurs who like don't know
how to move on from their business
when it's time they secretly stopped
liking it four years ago and they're
still
they're still doing it right
but they stay in it out of other reasons
obligations you know fear of what people
will say about them if they leave they
haven't hit their financial success yet
whatever
and doesn't mean you like abandon ship
right away but creating the path so that
this isn't what you're doing every day
or you're just afraid of
launching it what people will say it
won't work out
waste of money either way the answer is
action right like it's
it's don't do it and stop thinking about
it
or do it and finish it it's never stay
in
procrastination right so hopefully in
you know three more months it's not
still the same
issue for you where it's i don't know
what i
want to do
you could have your website done in
three months easy or you could
spend all that time thinking about it
and put it somewhere else that could
help your business grow
because maybe you don't need a website
you use you use facebook as your website
and maybe you need to research just to
get more information but you could do
that like this weekend you could
research everything about
a website and you could talk to friends
you can ask anybody hey do you know a
website developer
and you can have the conversations next
week to see if you should actually build
a website or not
and if the answer is yes and you can
build momentum
before the end of the year have a
website up
[Music]
if you want even more hacks on how to be
productive check out the video right
there next to me i think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there friday afternoon
few minutes make yourself a short three
category priority list for the next week
i want you to find 15 minutes today and
i want you
to slow down